do you think if Trump was on Twitter the
last six months it would have made any
difference on what happened last night
no any one of you you're saying it would
have got worse Okay Tyler saying no to
all of you you're saying no as well or
do you think he would have been able to
influence some of it I I don't know but
I would say this real quick maybe at the
end of this I could just pick my case on
why I wouldn't write Donald Trump off
yet I think he's uh very much still the
front runner to be the Republican
nominee we can talk about that a little
bit DeSantis was a big winner he's has
presidential aspirations I think it's
obvious
but I I have to say that uh one thing
about Donald Trump is he's been written
off many times and he always comes back
and when that Billy Bush tape came out
and during the race with Hillary and the
whole Republican establishment started
abandoning their nominee and we're
urging him to get out of the race who'da
thought he would have endured and
survived and overcome that so it's a
very different day in politics today my
hope for president Trump I have a bias
of course I'm grateful for what he did
for me and I think he's really LED our
country in many ways in in a positive
direction I think it's part of this
alignment we alignment that's appealing
to Latino voters and black men and all
the rest joined the Republican party I
think president Trump has reached out to
a different voting block and group to
try to broaden the Republican party and
recognize the demographic shifts in our
country
I'd like to see him become more the
uniter and I don't know he has that in
him can I ask you a question you're
Chicago so so Chicago you know who's the
greatest basketball player of all time
your future is right there okay Michael
Jordan's the greatest basketball player
of all time right you believe that I do
and I had dinner with him once it was
fantastic you put him as the cream of
the crop number one is it fair to say we
all believe the same things yeah the
greatest of all time okay Michael Jordan
over LeBron James any day of the week so
let me ask there's no Jordan deniers
here right yeah but here's the question
though well here's a question though
here's the question
be Michael Jordan for a second okay
the the saying has been he's the Jordan
of dot dot dot and that's been the case
for 25 years okay that label the name if
you were to say how many times people
said he's the Jordan of that that the
number is going to be in a billions it's
we're using it regularly right Brady
doesn't have that nobody says Gretzky
nobody says Willie Mays nobody says Babe
Ruth everybody says dmj the Jordan okay
do you think Jordan deep down inside is
a little bit threatened about LeBron
passing them up you think Jordan a
little bit inside is not happy about the
fact that if LeBron passes 40 000 points
you know if he wins one more chip gets
five do you think the Market's gonna
start saying listen and I think that guy
do you think he's threatened by it at
all no you're saying zero I'm saying no
you're saying zero or no I'm saying he's
not threatened okay MJ has one mantle
what would you say Rod what would you
say I would say yes I would say it's
incredibly competitive I think he's what
makes incredibly competitive right like
the comment about hey what do you think
about this kid Kobe Bryant the way he's
guarding you well he stole all my moves
like that's still a dig right he stole
all my messages right so so that's the
part where for me you know uh uh the
comment he made you know Trump just made
a comment he said what you know uh uh
this this sanctimonious right he says
Trump mocks Governor DeSantis has Ron
the sanctimonious at Pennsylvania rally
how do you think Trump is feeling last
night going to sleep not even going to
sleep he's up all night last night
because marjor green Kerry Lake all
these guys he's making phone calls he's
doing speeches he's doing all this stuff
how do you think he feels that no matter
what he looks what he reads everyone's
talking about the sentence knowing him
as a true competitor that he has to come
into a room and everybody stops for him
how do you think he feels knowing the
sentence is now the Superstar are the
right like Michael Jordan and LeBron
James just like that and Trump is a
tremendous competitor and the
presidential race is a marathon not a
Sprint and santis looks really good
right now
um Trump didn't have the best possible
night on the other hand some of his
candidates still won J.D Vance won very
well I still think Harry lake is going
to win it otherwise nobody thought that
was going to be happening Jay the events
wasn't like it was going to be a slam
dunk win go take a look he was outspent
four to one yeah exactly
um so you still think Kerry Lake's going
to win I do and I said and I I still
think put your money on Trump to be the
Republican nominee you can have a lot of
candidates in that race DeSantis is very
compelling but he's LeBron James to
Michael to Trump's Michael Jordan among
the Republican voters and when you have
a split vote like that 35 percent of the
loyal
Die Hard Trump voters are going to carry
Trump to victory in most of those
primaries but by the way if you're
watching this podcast we can fit 300
people here we're going to do a live
podcast with people being able to come
here live but we're going to do it when
we cross 500 000 Subs if you enjoying
this format the set and what we're doing
give us a sub click on the notification
and give us a thumbs up do you agree
with Roger said Adam
about uh Trump being about Trump and
DeSantis the fact that you know DeSantis
is LeBron Trump is Jordan in this kind
of an argument clearly Trump is
threatened by DeSantis
clearly Trump views himself as
you know the holy of all holies
to use the Michael Jordan LeBron analogy
right the reason that I don't think
LeBron will ever be on Michael Jordan's
level is because at the end of the day
what do you judge people on
championships Bill Russell is one of the
greatest players ever because he has 11
championships okay Mike MJ was 6-0 in
the finals What's LeBron's record like I
don't even know if it's 500 to be honest
exactly he's missed the playoffs yeah so
just on that basis you have someone
who's six and up has never lost in the
finals and you have someone who's
obviously an amazing player probably
will go down as number two of all time
but is not even batting 500 in the
finals so to use the Trump analogy
um Trump I think is more of a LeBron
than an MJ because
what's Trump's record
over the last eight years six years you
want to say one and one in presidential
election not presidential election but
when it comes to midterms he lost in
2018 he lost in 2020 and now he
technically lost in 2022. toward your
future looks bright hat click over here
and to watch the entire podcast click
here take care everybody
foreign
[Music]